I'm actually curious how long have you
been watching my videos because this
ties into how we first met as well I've
known you I mean obviously as I said
I've known you since the animes on it
that's like that's the line so just like
a long time but I think I like I watched
you probably not knowing that you will
like this like YouTube personality
because yeah yeah same yeah like cuz I
was in like a weird state I don't think
I discovered youtubers until maybe about
2011 yeah maybe because they've been
around for a long time since then yeah
and obviously you've been around since
then but I never like went on to YouTube
being like I'm gonna go check out my
favorite you just use YouTube up until
around 2011 I think I just use youtubers
to like either watch music or listen to
music videos or just to like oh this is
an interesting looking video yeah and I
think a couple of your videos will like
the interesting looking ones I think I
remember actually the first video I ever
watched from you surprisingly was not
able bridged oh sure I watched Ava
bridge when I like the idea of an O
breathing that sounds fun but tedious is
fun but um no I think the first video
what from you was oh god I probably want
to say it's the oh my god like the one
you didn't like mm I never even saw your
Eva haver a bridge yeah I just excited
and watch Davis wasn't what I watched
the Emperor I don't even know what this
is why would I watch that so I think I
don't I watched some of your stuff I
just knew you always the British one
yeah okay so the first time we met in
person so it was like a X mm and is it
17 it was 16 or 17 I think I think so
I knew Joey I didn't know that he knew
who I was right and vice versa
I knew God but I didn't know if he knew
me yeah so this was back when I had like
if you didn't know I took a hiatus on on
YouTube for like two years because I got
a real time a real job and everything
like that and in that time I had gone
from being like one of the most popular
anime youtubers to just you know to
someone who taken i8s and in that time
Joey had like
exploded like you you were you reached
numbers that's back in my time I didn't
know was even [ __ ] possible like you
you were like close to a million you
were like like hot [ __ ] at the time yeah
so the first time welcome so the first
time I saw Joey we were like in Little
Tokyo or something yeah yeah I remember
exactly where it was - it was that part
in like the back half of Little Tokyo
yeah right it's like underneath a
building and you go into where the like
a figurine shop yeah yeah yeah and you
were walking with Jeff right yeah yeah
that's right Jeff because I think Jeff
said hello to misty because they're both
tall [ __ ] just like standing
next to two [ __ ] skyscrapers well
we're just hanging out and I remember
looking at you and you look to me and we
didn't say [ __ ] to each other and I
thought this I thought this [ __ ]
must hate me
this [ __ ] hates me that's the
same time I like gun and I like looked
at each other in the eyes and in my head
I was like this guy definitely hates me
this guy hates my guts so I'm just like
man show me such an arrogant piece of
[ __ ] I can't believe this guy ma'am but
we shook hands we were like hi I'm joy
nice to meet you like hi I'm gone I said
that was it that was it
I've never heard this well because the
only people who were there was misty
Jeff and hockey yeah thinking nice - so
it was like very small and then what
like fast forward like what - I think it
was just I don't think it was next year
we might you might have been even less
than that when I came to Egypt went on
to a trip to Japan or something and then
you randomly DM to me yeah yeah yeah
like for some reason he follows me so
maybe he doesn't hate me oh cool he's
cool so yeah we we DMD each other and
then we met in Japan and then we just
like instantly Italy just like [ __ ]
great friends you know we went to in is
like no we met up in Akihabara yeah and
we like hung out a little bit and then
we went to an izakaya Elena yeah yeah
it's all like
in the morning yeah like something
ridiculous like that we missed the last
trip yeah and then we were like sounds
like a bromance we missed the last train
we had so much fun because we had the
moment when we just we were seeing it on
in there he's like izakaya and I was
like I thought you hated me and I was
like I bought you a to me